[Musique]
c'est un témoignage rare celui d'une
femme qui a été régulièrement violée par
son mari
Anita Sarkar 30 ans à accepter de nous
raconter son histoire
un calvaire de près de 10 ans
il m'agressait sexuellement tous les
jours et si j'osais lui dire non il me
frappait sans cesse il me forçait à
coucher avec lui au quotidien il
s'allongeait sur moi et m'enlever mes
vêtements de force et après il me tirait
vers lui alors que je lui disais non il
me forçait même à l'embrasser
ce qui m'est arrivé c'est du viol quand
on ne veut pas ça s'appelle un viol et
c'est ce qu'il faisait même quand je
disais non il ne m'écoutait pas
[Musique]
rester impuni car Anita ne peux pas
porter plainte la loi indienne ne
reconnaît toujours pas le viol conjugal
Noémie
je vais porter plainte contre lui parce
qu'il m'a fait énormément souffrir sans
aucune raison et après il a demandé le
divorce
le cas d'Anita est loin d'être unique
si le viol est bien considéré comme un
crime en Inde une exception dans le code
pénal indique qu'au sein d'un couple
marié ce crime n'existe pas
c'est cet article de loi que tente de
faire tomber deux associations de
défense des droits des femmes auprès de
la Haute cour de New Delhi
leur pétition s'appuie sur le témoignage
d'une victime de viol conjugal qui
souhaite rester anonyme
pour son avocat c'est un combat pour
changer la loi mais également les
mentalités
discrime le crime de viol conjugal a été
reconnu dans la quasi-totalité du monde
je ne pense pas qu'il y est une
démocratie qui ne reconnaisse pas le
viol conjugal et ne le punisse pas comme
un crime
mais en Inde la plus grande démocratie
du monde ce n'est toujours pas le cas
d'après une étude qui a été menée
récemment dans plusieurs États indiens
60 % des hommes dans ces États ont avoué
qu'ils avaient des relations sexuelles
avec leurs femmes même si elle disait
non
selon des chiffres officiels publiés en
2015 par le ministère de la Famille
5,4 % des femmes indiennes mariées ont
déclaré avoir déjà été victime de viol
de la part de leur époux ou conjoint des
chiffres largement sous-estimés selon
plusieurs associations comme celle-ci
depuis 4 décennies action India aide les
femmes victimes de violences sexuelles à
trouver une porte de sortie une aide
juridique mais surtout un espace
d'échange et un soutien moral
nous vivons dans une société où les
femmes ne peuvent pas penser par
elle-même
si si votre mari veut vous forcer à
coucher avec lui on a pas le droit
d'appeler ça un viol
conjugal un sujet toujours tabou dans
une société qui considère encore que
répondre aux demandes sexuelles du mari
fait partie des devoirs de la femme
aucune femme qui vient ici ne comprends
ce qui lui est arrivé mais au moins
après être venu nous voir elles arrivent
à mettre des mots sur leur traumatisme
elles en parlent plus facilement
le débat autour du viol conjugal
rencontre un large écho dans la société
indienne mais aussi de la Résistance
sur les réseaux sociaux un hashtag
maritstrike ou greffe du mariage a fait
son apparition au début des audiences à
la Haute Cour les hommes qui suivent ce
mouvement refusent de se marier jusqu'à
nouvel ordre ils s'inquiète qu'une
criminalisation du viol conjugal pousse
les femmes à porter de fausses
accusations à leur rencontre à l'origine
de ce hashtag cet ancienne ingénieur
soit oupsar car je suis attentivement
les débats son association de protection
des hommes s'oppose à la criminalisation
du viol conjugal
quand on parle du consentement des
femmes il faut aussi considérer celui
des maris
font aussi des efforts parfois ils ne se
sont pas bien ils sont fatigués après le
travail et leur femme veut avoir une
relation sexuelle alors que le mari n'en
a pas vraiment envie mais il le fait
aussi parce que sa femme on a envie
est-ce que vous allez me dire qu'une
femme est une violeuse si elle viole le
consentement et le désert de son mari
de son côté le gouvernement indien s'est
ouvertement prononcé contre le
changement de cette loi
estimant qu'il s'agissait d'une attaque
contre l'institution du mariage
selon de nombreuses associations cette
position banalisent les agressions
sexuelles au sein des couples mariés en
Inde
[Applaudissements]